كيف يستطيع الناس مواصله حياتهم تحت القصف
وكيف يختبر الدمار قناعاتهم لقد دمرت
المدفعيه الروسيه مدينه بخموت بصوره شبه
كامله وفر معظم سكانها البارقي عددهم
70000 بل انه لمن النادر ان ترى جنديا
اوكرانيا في شوارعها معرضا نفسه
يحاولون الدخول الى المدينه
[موسيقى]
حده القصف في باخموت امر شديد الوضوح
والقوات الروسيه على بعد نحو كيلومتر
واحدا في هذا الاتجاه
يشعر الجيش الاوكراني
بسبب المكاسب التي حققتها القوه الروسيه
في محيط سوليدار الى الشمال من باخمود وهي
الان تحاول تطويق المدينه بصوره كامله
[موسيقى]
التقطت كاميراتنا المثبته على مقدمه
السياره لحظه سقوط ما يعتقد انهما قديفتان
مدفعي كالبر من عيار 120 على منزل مهجور
في الجهه المقابل من الشارع
وقد حطمت قوه الانفجار زجاجه السياره
القصه نفسها تدور في الجانب الاخر من
المدينه حيث تحاول القوات الروسيه الضغطه
من الاتجاه الجنوبي الشرقي
بين الروس يعززون قوتهم هناك
قذف المدفعي اوكراني من حكومه قريبه معركه
بخموت تزداد حده مع مرور الوقت